hello everyone myself my name is
i'm affiliated with autumn institute of
science and technology children my kids
to tell you the same word learning and
memory neurodegeneration and dementia
i'm also interested in vision neutral
science and electrophysiology
today i'm going to present my project
work
entitled transcriptomic analysis of
hippocampal circles open in alzheimer's
diseases
before proceding i would love to give an
overview of alzheimer's disease it is a
neurodegenerative disorder affecting
mainly the elder population there are
several hypotheses here in this disease
one of them are tau hypothesis another
is betad amyloid hypothesis
ready results in several cognitive
declines such as memory loss lack of
loss of patient
lack of special and temporal senses
brain atrophy newton climation
mitochondrial dysfunction and oxidative
stress and disruption of calcium
diposity plus
homeostasis other neurodegenerative
disorders include parkinson's stresses
hunting stress diseases lewy body
diseases myelotropic lateral steroids
frederick adacia etc
three single gene mutations associated
with adr amyloid recursive protein on
provision 21 present in one on comment
in 2014 present into one chromosome 1.
hippocampus is known
it's
the center for learning and memory which
is why very affected in enzyme stresses
here in our project the focus is
hypocritical circle c a1
so so here is an overview what we have
done in
the project work
after the labeling of data we perform
quantile normalization and principal
component analysis so here is our result
we can see the plot of
principle component 1 1 personal
principle component 2
principle component one versus principal
component three principal component two
versus principal component three
the principal component one accounts for
twenty three point zero one percent
variation principle component two
accounts from 18.219 percent variation
principal component 3 accounts from
14.75
variation
based on these results
we uh detected this particular sample as
a outlet from our data we get to know
this is not this sample is basically x 1
1
9 which is an
a d sample we decided to remove the this
outlier
so
so here are the results of our juicer
enrichment analysis
so here we can see this is a a volcano
plotted
here the x-axis represents log to four
chain and the y axis is the the adjusted
value in logarithm
in logarithmic format
so red dots here are the significant
genes say where the blue dot shows the
non-significant one say
the right side showed positive
regulation
of the genes and the left side shows a
negative appropriation of certain genes
the most significantly
upregulated genes are mentioned here
here is another plot it is insert
ontology enriched pathways so as i can
see here there are uh activated
pathways and suppressed pathways
this uh
the size of the circle represents the
overall gene count at the bottom of
these boxes the gene ratio is mentioned
the most significant uh statistically
significant ones are the red ones while
the least
statistically significant ones are the
blue ones here in this plot all samples
are statistically significant
so here is the synonym plot of the gene
uh networks
here we can see the color of the node
represents the fold change and the size
of the node represents
the size of the
genes so here are the genes and here are
the some down regulated
gene ontology terms here for change is
negative
so it is a result of cage enriched
pathway again here are activated methods
and here are the
uh surprise patterns the gene count is
uh represent by the size represented by
the size of the circle and here is the
uh we can see the red uh signifies the
statistical significant ones and the
blues uh here represents the
statistically non-significant words
non-significant ones and the uh range of
the p adjusted value here is from zero
to point one
we can see here both activated under
suppressed cage enriched pathways
here is another uh vein diagram between
the two uh
226 genes uh
of supplementary table s5
and here is 181 genes say uh that is the
statistically significant uh genes from
our uh output file after ginseng
adjustment analysis and shorting only
the statistically significant one we
found zero overlappings in say and we
conclude that it might be due to the
fact our
our uh project is very much focused on
the hippocampal surface ca1
uh c1 whereas the main study uh
uh took
like
considered
every uh field of the jacob campus
would love to conclude our uh project
with the uh the fact that we have done
both the gene ontology analysis and k
generation geo terms such as neuronal
actin potential transmitter gated
channel activity neurotransmitters
signal separation neuropathy signaling
pathway are upregulated another notable
mentions on olfactory receptor activity
and detection of chemical stimulus
involved in sensory perception
hippocampus is widely known as for its
role in learning and memory these
activated geos with respect to circle c
a1 could give us new directions for
future research
the same kind of analysis could be
conducted for other circles of
hippocampus as well limitations of the
study is
uh
lack of validation digit
therefore we wish to do further analysis
if possible
major came in splashing in the
successful completion of my project
entitled transcriptomic analysis of
hippocampal surface ca1 in alzheimer's
disease i would love to acknowledge my
research method dr raghavendra lakshmi
narayan and dr elia broadsky i would
love so love
i would love also love to sorry i would
also love to uh express my gratitude
uh to other members of the team
including but not limited to miss
srinaly karai his fashion and dr mohit
i am indebted to all of them without
their customers supported and motivation
this project would never have been
possible
thank you all thank you for listening to
me